Namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma sambuddhassa Namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma sambuddhassa Namo tassa bhagavato harahato
Hommage au Bouddha, le Nobile bénévole et complètement autonome.
Hier, nous avons abordé cette zone du non-Self.
hier nous avons investigué ou nous avons traité le sujet du non-soi et il y a toujours quelque chose qu'on aurait voulu dire et qu'on n'a pas dit alors voilà, juste une ou deux choses
Alors, on confond l'état de bonheur avec le nibbana.
Excusez-moi.
Alors, on a tendance à confondre le bonheur lié au Nibbana avec le bonheur qu'on a comme être humain.
Non, émotionnel.
Désolée, désolée, désolée.
Avec un...
Voilà, tout le monde a compris avant moi.
Voilà, confondre avec l'émotion, le bonheur sous forme d'émotion.
Voilà, j'y arrive.
Alors, quand Sariputta demanda...
Quel est le bliss ?
Non, quelqu'un a demandé à Sariputta.
Ah, quelqu'un a demandé à Sariputta.
Désolé, j'ai dû me déconnecter.
Comment peux-tu parler de l'état de...
L'état.
l'extase du Nibbana lorsqu'il n'y a pas d'émotion dans le Nibbana Sariputta répondit c'est l'absence d'émotion qui est effectivement la source de l'extase
Delibana.
Oui, j'ai de la peine avec l'extase, voilà.
C'est ça mon problème, c'est l'extase.
J'ai de la peine avec ce mot, voilà.
Alors, quand tu es dans l'état très clair de l'observateur,
à l'intérieur de nous-mêmes, quand vous réfléchissez sur cet état, quel est cet état dans lequel vous êtes en qualité d'observateur ?
à savoir à l'intérieur de celui qui observe.
De quoi ça consiste ?
Alors il va nous laisser avec cette question.
Objectivité ?
Non.
Qu'est-ce qui arrive à la personne qui est pleinement libérée après sa mort ?
Alors là, on a deux traditions de pensée.
D'abord, il y a les Theravadas qui disent que
elle ou il reste dans cet état d'extase.
Mais les Mahayanas enseignent que, attirés par la compassion, le Bouddha réapparaît constamment.
Mais le Mahajanana enseigne que le Bouddha, pris par la compassion qu'il a pour les êtres, revient et réapparaît continuellement.
Et donc vous pouvez choisir entre ces deux versions.
Ok.
Donc ce soir, j'ai vraiment voulu retourner aux bases.
Alors ce soir, je voulais en fait revenir aux bases de l'enseignement.
Et de revenir sur les quatre nobles vérités.
Et je crois qu'on arrivera à voir comme l'enseignement du Bouddha est finalement assez simple, tout en étant très clair.
Alors, c'est tous ces érudits et ces intellectuels qui rendent ça tout très difficile et compliqué.
Voilà, donc en fait, il va le lire en anglais, mais il n'y a pas la traduction française, donc il faudra être un peu patient avec moi.
Alors,
Alors, ceci est la noble vérité de la souffrance.
Alors, le mot utilisé par le Bouddha, c'est dukkha.
Et nous ne pouvons pas obtenir la fulness de la signification de ce mot dans n'importe quelle de nos langues occidentales.
Et en fait, on n'arrive pas à cerner l'entièreté de la signification de ce mot dans nos langages de l'Occident.
Et d'ailleurs, les traducteurs utilisent des mots différents.
Et le plus généralement utilisé, c'est « l'insatisfaction ».
Mais il y a un écrivain qui appelle ça stress.
Dukkha, ça peut sonner juste pour nous.
Dukkha veut dire simplement difficile à supporter.
La route est difficile, kha,
La racine du mot, c'est dur à supporter.
Et il y a des suggestions que ça a été employé pour les rayons de la roue.
Et ça ne fit pas bien.
Et que, en fait, que ce n'était pas adapté, que ça ne s'intégrait pas de manière adéquate.
Et donc, que la roue ne fonctionnait pas correctement, qu'elle tremblait.
Ensuite, il nous dit que la naissance est souffrance.
Correct.
Donc, en fait, oui, la naissance c'est souffrance, pour la mère c'est souffrance et pour l'enfant aussi.
C'est très rare qu'un bébé, qu'un nourrissant, sorte du ventre de sa maman en souriant.
Et s'il sourit, de toute façon, le médecin va lui donner un coup.
Va le secouer, plutôt.
Va le secouer.
Et ensuite, il dit, vieillir, c'est souffrir.
La maladie, c'est la souffrance.
Et la mort, c'est la souffrance.
Donc, quand il parle de souffrance, il parle de...
Il inclut deux types de souffrance.
Il y a la souffrance donnée, et il y a comment nous réagissons à elle, qui est une autre souffrance.
Voilà, il y a la souffrance qui nous est donnée et il y a l'autre souffrance, c'est celle qui est nos réactions à cette souffrance.
Donc la vie elle-même ne nous offre pas
une santé physique parfaite sans souffrance dans ce sens de devoir vivre comme un être humain une forme de désespoir physique ou de douleur nous arrivera
Alors, de par le fait d'être un être humain sur la Terre, il y a forcément de l'inconfort physique ou de la souffrance physique qui est impliquée dans cette vie humaine.
Et la souffrance réelle, c'est comment nous réagissons à cela par la façon d'une version de la peur.
Alors la vraie souffrance consiste en notre réaction à cette souffrance, soit sous la forme d'aversion, soit sous la forme de peur.
Et le Bouddha appelle ceci dukkha dukkha, la souffrance qui arrive à cause de la souffrance.
la souffrance qui est engendrée par la souffrance et rappelez-vous que cette seconde souffrance n'est pas nécessaire à d'autres moments dans les écritures il parle de deux fléchettes la première est donnée la deuxième est optionnelle
la première fléchette est donnée et la deuxième est à option la contemplation de la mort est l'une des plus fortes c'est l'une des manières les plus compétentes d'approcher Nibbana
La contemplation de la mort est un des moyens les plus habiles pour approcher ou pour aller vers le Nibbana.
La mort est le fin de tout ce que nous savons, présumons, appréhendons, n'appréhendons pas de notre vie.
Alors la mort c'est la fin de tout ce qu'on peut présumer, de tout ce qu'on apprécie, de tout ce qu'on rejette dans notre vie.
C'est la fin de tout.
Et cela consiste pour nous, la mort, une forme de terreur.
Cela représente pour nous une forme de terreur.
Et
et juste en amenant à l'esprit la mort je vais mourir, mon corps va mourir et de se le répéter encore et toujours
Et attendez la réaction.
C'est une pratique qui permet de faire face à la mort à quelques moments que ce soit de notre vie.
Rappelez-vous que ce sentiment de soi que nous avons parlé hier soir
Et rappelez-vous que ce sentiment que nous avons d'un moi sait dans le fond que ceci n'est pas réel.
Et si c'était réel et que ça durait une éternité, eh bien, ça n'aurait pas peur de la mort.
Non.
Alors la réunion avec ce qui est déplaisant constitue une souffrance.
Et d'un autre côté, la séparation de ce qui est plaisant est également de la souffrance.
C'est parfaitement simple.
Mais c'est comme si il faut se le répéter, il faut se l'enfoncer, il faut se le marteler, marteler dans le crâne.
Marteler.
Parce que nous sommes constamment dans la distraction.
Maintenant, avoir à porter
Alors de devoir supporter la souffrance est quelque chose qui soit engendre de la souffrance supplémentaire ou n'en engendre pas.
Rappelez-vous de cela.
Il y a les deux options.
Et notre réaction à cela
Et rappelez-vous donc qu'il y a cette souffrance qui est donnée, qui n'est pas option, et il y a l'autre qui est celle qu'on peut ne pas avoir.
Alors ces deux derniers jours, nous avons dû entendre ces jeunes en train de jouer au basketball.
C'est comme de la torture chinoise.
Comment avez-vous réagi à cela ?
Alors, si ça vous ennuyait, si ça vous énervait,
et que vous considériez que c'était une nuisance et bien vous vous êtes créé de la souffrance alors en fait dans le vipassana le corps de l'enseignement c'est d'accepter tout phénomène qui peut se produire
Et sans rajouter de la souffrance.
Et à ce moment-là, il n'y a justement pas de souffrance.
S'il y a acceptation, il n'y a pas de souffrance.
En fait, l'objet de la méditation, c'était le son du ballon contre le sol.
Vous pointez au deuxième type de souffrance, ou au premier ?
la première c'est le boum boum boum la deuxième c'est l'irritation mais c'est accepté et il n'y a pas d'aversion la première c'est juste l'inconnu du son consistant et doux ce n'est pas agréable
Ça peut l'être, ça peut l'être pour toi.
Je préférerais pas l'avoir là-bas, personnellement.
Quand vous vivez dans un endroit où le voisin à l'arrière a un gros rocher.
Un gros rocher.
oui quand vous avez un voisin qui est en train d'écouter du rock et tout ce que vous pouvez entendre c'est... et vous commencez à danser avec ça si vous êtes irrité avec ça
Alors, si vous vous fâchez avec cela, puis ça vous énerve, est-ce que vous avez remarqué que votre oreille reste collée au mur ?
Oui !
Oui, si vous lâchez cette irritation, ça reste en arrière-fond, et puis ça n'empêche pas que vous puissiez continuer ce que vous faites.
Alors, une fois, j'ai vécu dans une maison à Londres, et puis le métro souterrain passait juste devant.
Donc, d'environ 3h du matin,
Et donc à partir de 3 heures du matin, la maison dans laquelle il se trouvait était secouée, périodiquement secouée.
Comme j'étais un étudiant joyeux et plein d'entrain, cela ne m'inquiétait pas.
Après les premières deux ou trois nuits, je ne l'ai jamais entendu.
Après les deux ou trois premières nuits, je ne l'entendais même plus.
Mais il y avait bien d'autres choses qui me dérangeaient pourtant.
Alors la séparation de ce qui est plaisant, c'est de la souffrance.
Oui, alors par exemple, c'est ça qu'on expérimente avec le repas.
Si on a de la peine à lâcher ses plaisirs,
ou même ces déplaisirs, ces situations désagréables, c'est là où on se crée de la souffrance.
Et voilà, il y a une autre souffrance, c'est celle de ne pas obtenir ce que l'on veut.
Je souffre parce que je n'obtiens pas ce que je veux.
Alors, ça, ce sont des catégories qu'on peut amener à l'esprit dans notre vie courante.
Par exemple, on peut se rendre compte qu'effectivement, on est en train d'être dans le mode je n'obtiens pas ce que je veux.
Et puis, on peut lâcher ça et dire mais c'est bête, finalement.
Et en bref,
les cinq agrégats qui sont sujets à la clinging de s'agripper sont aussi sources de souffrance hier nous avons étudié les cinq agrégats du point de vue du moi le corps le ressenti
Alors rappelez-vous, il y avait le corps, le ressenti, les sensations et les perceptions.
Et toutes nos habitudes ainsi que les actes de cognition.
Maintenant, quand le Bouddha a été complètement libéré, il avait encore ces cinq aggregates.
Et lorsque le Bouddha fut pleinement réalisé, il avait toujours ces cinq agrégats.
Mais ils n'étaient pas, ils s'agrippaient pas.
Et le pire des croyances qu'on peut avoir,
c'est que ceci est permanent au niveau du corps ou au niveau de l'âme ou de l'esprit.
Alors nous nous comportons de telle façon à toujours essayer d'atteindre le bonheur
Mais en fait, nous nous y prenons mal parce qu'en fait, ce qu'on fait ne permet pas d'arriver à ce but.
L'illusion fondamentale d'un être est qu'il peut se rendre heureux dans un monde transiant.
Alors, la croyance erronée que nous avons à la base, qui sous-tend à toute chose, c'est qu'on peut avoir un moi heureux dans ce monde alors que celui-ci est impermanent.
Et ça fait tout en quelque chose de solide.
Et en fait, justement, cette croyance de faire que toutes choses ont de la consistance, ont de la substance.
Et le sentiment qu'il y a un moi, qu'il y a une substance,
est en fait rebise en question par le fait que dans le fond, il y a sans arrêt des changements.
Et maintenant, comment savons-nous lorsque ce faux moi se manifeste ?
Et ça, c'est précisément
la noble vérité de l'origine de la souffrance et l'origine de la souffrance n'est pas quelque part dans le passé mais c'est bel et bien ici et maintenant chaque moment, quand nous agissons de cette fausse compréhension ça commence avec cette cause originale
Et à chaque instant, lorsque nous avons une compréhension erronée, ça commence avec cette mauvaise origine-là.
Et c'est cette avidité qui conduit à l'existence qui ne cesse de se renouveler, enfin de continuer.
Not life after life, moment after moment.
And accompanied by delight and lust.
Seeking delight here and there.
Just the restlessness of trying to find the next excitement.
Juste cette dispersion de vouloir trouver à tout prix la prochaine source de plaisir.
The next distraction.
La distraction suivante.
That is the craving for sensual pleasures.
et ça c'est donc l'habilité en lien avec les plaisirs sensuels voilà, alors on ne parle pas que des plaisirs physiques mais on parle aussi des plaisirs qui viennent par le biais de tous nos sens donc c'est aussi le sens du cœur c'est aussi les relations
Voilà, alors donc c'est aussi en lien avec le cœur, c'est aussi dans les relations avec autrui, et c'est aussi l'art.
Alors, en d'autres termes, d'un point de vue purement du non réalisé,
d'une personne non réalisée, on est toujours en quête de se rendre heureux, de trouver des divertissements.
Et ensuite, il y a cette avidité qui se présente d'exister.
Et donc on a constamment envie de devenir quelqu'un, de progresser, de devenir une célébrité, de devenir quelque chose.
Voilà, par exemple il peut s'agir de pouvoir ou de statut.
Et finalement, l'avidité qui pousse au néant.
à l'absence d'existence.
Et d'ailleurs dans ce cas, ça peut être poussé à l'extrême jusqu'au suicide.
Mais considérez,
Quand vous avez été un petit peu déprimé, un peu ennuyé, etc. Est-ce que vous vous êtes jamais allongé simplement sur le canapé ?
Et juste de s'endormir ?
Non.
Avez-vous jamais...
est-ce que ça vous est déjà arrivé le dimanche matin de rester un petit peu dans le lit et de passer, d'être là pour ce petit moment sublime ?
Voilà, cet état transitoire entre le sommeil et l'état d'éveil, cet état intermédiaire.
Parfois, nous avons envie de nous débarrasser de nous-mêmes, nous avons envie de dormir.
Le désir de devenir inconscient est le désir d'annihiler nous-mêmes.
Le désir de devenir inconscient, c'est justement le désir de vouloir ne plus être.
Et comment ça, ça se manifeste dans notre méditation ?
Ça se manifeste sous forme de torpeur et sous forme de fatigue.
Il y a beaucoup de fatigue, hein ?
N'est-ce pas qu'il y en a beaucoup ?
Oui, c'est très simple en fait.
Le Bouddha pointe du doigt simplement cette qualité du désir.
Et rappelez-vous que ça, ça constitue le mauvais désir qui surgit de la mauvaise compréhension.
Et c'est pour ça que dans notre vie courante, il est très important d'être conscient de nos intentions et ceci dans le but de viser au vrai bonheur.
Parce que nos intentions sont en fait en train de manufacturer nos états mentaux.
Il y a bien entendu des désirs qui viennent du cœur et de la sagesse.
Voici le constat radical.
Vous n'avez jamais un tel constat dans la psychologie moderne.
C'est la vérité noble de la cessation du souffrance.
Voici la noble vérité de la cessation de la souffrance.
En d'autres termes, il y a une réelle possibilité d'en terminer définitivement avec la souffrance.
En quoi consiste cette complète éradication de la souffrance ?
C'est le fait de la réduction jusqu'à ce qu'il n'y ait plus rien et la cessation
et la cessation de cette habilité le lâcher prise et l'abandon la liberté de cela le non-attachement donc ce que le Bouddha dit ici c'est que la réponse est dans ce processus de désir
Alors ce que le Bouddha nous dit ici c'est que la réponse est en fait dans le processus du désir.
Alors désir ici dans le sens des intentions.
Et ainsi il en déduit que c'est extrêmement simple.
Tout ce qu'il faut faire
Alors tout ce qu'il faut faire, c'est très simple, c'est d'être suffisamment éveillé pour percevoir chaque intention que nous avons.
Et si nous voyons
que cela n'est pas adapté, n'est pas saint, n'est pas vertueux, et bien il faut simplement le lâcher et le laisser passer.
Et quand nous voyons une intention qui est vertueuse, alors dans ce cas nous lui donnons plus d'énergie, nous lui donnons plus de pouvoir.
Le Bouddha a dit que si nous arrivons à garder ce niveau de conscience et de présence à l'instant pour cette année et bien au bout de cette année nous serions pleinement libérés.
Alors, soit pleinement libéré, ou alors celui qui ne doit pas revenir.
Et donc, c'est une étape qui est très proche de celle d'être pleinement libéré.
Alors, il dit, n'importe 7 ans, 7 mois,
Et il dit, qu'importe sept ans, sept mois.
Et ensuite il dit, qu'importe sept mois, sept jours.
Sept jours.
Si nous pouvions garder cette attention pour sept jours.
Nous ne pouvons pas la garder pour sept secondes.
Si nous pouvions garder cette attention pour sept jours, sept jours seulement, mais on n'arrive pas à garder l'attention pour sept secondes.
Et ensuite, il décrit le noble octuple sentier.
Oui.
Et c'est vraiment un bon moment pour parler de prendre cette pratique dans la vie quotidienne.
Donc, dans cet 8ème chemin, ça commence avec cette bonne attitude, cette bonne intention.
et dans ce noble octuple sentier ça commence avec justement la bonne attitude la bonne intention et cela se manifeste de trois manières différentes cela se manifeste dans notre pensée cela se manifeste sous forme de nos paroles
Et cela se manifeste sous la forme de nos actions.
Voilà, puis le plus difficile c'est l'esprit ou le mental parce que ça va tellement vite.
Et donc c'est très important dans la vie de tous les jours de donner à l'esprit quelque chose à faire.
Comme je l'ai dit avant, il y a bien des fois où, en fait, durant la journée, nous ne faisons pas grand-chose.
Et en fait, ça consiste vraiment à s'encourager soi-même de ne pas perdre son temps durant ces petites périodes de temps.
Je parle de ces petits moments, comme par exemple attendre un bus, attendre un train, monter les escaliers, attendre un ami...
il y a tous ces petits moments là où en fait il est très important de ne pas perdre son temps voilà alors c'est le point c'est de prendre la détermination de s'engager à les utiliser et puis choisir quelque chose que vous allez en fait faire
Et ensuite de choisir quelque chose que vous allez concrètement faire.
Ça peut être aussi simple que de s'ouvrir à la conscience à l'instant.
Quand nous avons fait la méditation de position, vous voyez, juste recevoir ce que l'environnement nous donne.
Donc, c'est juste être ouvert aux données sensuelles.
alors c'est juste de s'ouvrir à tout le data sensuel ou l'essence et à ces moments là je suis convaincue que le fait de noter peut vous aider et cela évitera que l'esprit se disperse et puis il y a Metta bien sûr vous pouvez le faire aux gens autour de vous
Et ensuite, il y a la pratique du Metta.
Vous pouvez faire ça pour les gens autour de vous, par exemple.
Et il y a un petit exercice que vous pourriez trouver extraordinairement puissant.
Et durant la journée, quand vous avez juste une petite pause, à chaque fois que vous avez une petite pause, juste dire merci.
Merci pour les trains, merci pour les gens qui conduisent les trains, merci pour les tracks de trains, merci pour les fleurs.
merci pour les trains merci aux conducteurs des trains merci aux rails des trains et merci aussi pour les mouches d'ailleurs il y en a une qui est là dans cette pièce et qui aime bien venir sur ma tête yes I'm persecuted so
Alors tout ce qui concerne justement ces fameuses pensées, alors tout est finalement où est-ce qu'on porte notre attention.
Alors chaque fois qu'il y a un acte d'attention,
cela doit intégrer une intention et de ce fait on en déduit qu'il y a conditionnement et donc on doit faire attention finalement à ce que nous lisons à ce que nous regardons
Vous savez, ces grands posters avec des publicités qui sont de part et d'autre des autres, des routes, pardon.
Il y a 20 ou 25 ans, en Angleterre,
Les gens qui payaient pour ces grands pancartes, eh bien, croyaient que finalement, ça ne marchait pas.
Ça ne servait à rien.
Ces pancartes ne valaient pas l'argent qu'on leur demandait de payer.
Ce n'était pas un moyen habile pour faire de la publicité.
Donc les propriétaires des pancartes ont créé un adverteur.
Et donc les propriétaires de ces panneaux en fait ils firent eux-mêmes une publicité.
Et ils mirent l'image d'un parfum d'ailleurs qui provient d'Australie et qui avait pour nom Billabong.
On the bottle it had a hat that you might see from Australians with corks hanging down.
Yes, yes.
Et sur le haut de la bouteille de parfum, il y avait un chapeau et en fait, sous le chapeau collé, il y avait des bouchons qui l'ornaient.
And it had a telephone number.
Et il y avait aussi un numéro téléphoné.
So many inquiries.
Il y a énormément de gens qui apprennent.
Et en fait, le nom du parfum, c'était en fait les écrans qui étaient publiés.
C'était le nom du... Non, non, quand tu es assis sur le bus.
En fait, énormément de gens ont appelé et effectivement, parce que quand on est sur un bus, on est un peu dans un état passif et puis voilà, et puis on absorbe les informations.
Donc, le numéro de téléphone inscrit sur le panneau, plein de gens, ensuite de l'avoir vu, ont téléphoné.
Ah, c'est ça.
Alors, le Bouddha nous demande de prêter attention au mental, à l'esprit, et en fait, tout commence à cet endroit-là.
Et d'ailleurs, toute la technologie qui existe aujourd'hui, où est-ce que tout ça a commencé ?
alors le langage est aussi un sujet très difficile bien souvent nous disons des choses et ensuite nous le regrettons et parfois nous ne pensons pas avant de parler
Donc, c'est une autre petite technique que nous pouvons introduire dans nos vies, c'est de ne pas être si rapide avec nos réponses, en disant des choses.
Le Bouddha dit que notre parole doit être gentille,
Le Bouddha dit que notre façon de parler doit être gentille.
Ça doit être honnête.
Et le plus important, ça doit être dit au moment voulu, au moment adapté.
Ce n'est pas bon pour dire « je suis gentil et je suis honnête ».
c'est pas suffisant de dire je suis en train d'être gentil et je suis en train de dire la vérité c'est aussi très important d'attendre le moment adapté ensuite nous avons l'action juste donc c'est vraiment tout ce que nous faisons tant que ce n'est pas inutile c'est bon
Voilà, alors c'est tout ce que nous faisons, finalement.
Et puis, il faut que ce soit, dans la mesure du possible, vertueux.
Finalement, c'est ça.
Il faut que ce soit vertueux.
D'ailleurs, la plupart d'entre nous, nous savons cela.
Et là, ce qui est intéressant, c'est qu'il inclut également le juste moyen de gagner sa vie.
Hum.
parce que ça pourrait être finalement ça pourrait être intégré dans les actions l'action juste et si nous considérons que dans la plupart de notre vie nous investissons une grande partie de notre temps dans le travail que nous faisons et que le travail que nous faisons
et que le travail que nous faisons développe en nous une certaine forme de personnalité ou de caractère.
Alors, à titre d'illustration, on peut s'imaginer qu'il y a une très grande différence entre une infirmière d'un côté et un soldat de l'autre.
il y a une demande de qualités différentes en fonction du métier et quand nous regardons la profession que nous exerçons Bante nous invite à réfléchir
quelles sont les qualités que nous devons développer en lien avec ce métier.
Et rappelez-vous que toutes ces qualités ont leur contrepartie ennemie.
Je suppose que la meilleure chose serait un ennemi subtil.
Il y a un ennemi évident et un ennemi plus subtil.
Voilà, il y a deux choses.
Il y a un ennemi qui est très évident et il y a un ennemi qui est plus subtil.
Alors, par exemple, l'ennemi de l'amour, c'est la haine.
Et l'ennemi subtil, c'est l'attachement.
Parce que, rappelez-vous, quand nous avons un amour qui est distorsé par l'attachement,
Cela signifie que nous utilisons la personne pour notre bénéfice.
Hum...
Pour le courage, c'est la lâcheté.
Intrépide.
Témérité Témérité Témérité Témérité Témérité Témérité Témérité Témérité Témérité
Alors, pour ce qui concerne votre travail, vous vous posez la question de la liste des vertus que vous pouvez développer grâce à ce travail.
Et juste de vérifier si ces vertus peuvent être en fait contrecarrées par un ennemi subtil.
Alors,
la qualité du service alors l'attitude de service c'est de mettre à disposition
vos qualités, donc plutôt vos talents pour en faire bénéficier dans vous-même dans les personnes pour qui vous travaillez et par extension l'ensemble de la société, de la collectivité alors si ce travail est fait avec l'intention correcte qui est une offre
Et en fait, ça, il s'agit d'une offrande, d'un service rendu.
Sans qu'il y ait de ficelle attachée, sans qu'il y ait quelque chose attendu en retour.
Si votre talent n'est pas voulu, ou non accepté, ou ignoré,
Alors si vos talons ne sont pas acceptés, ne sont pas souhaités, ne sont pas acceptés ou carrément qui sont complètement ignorés, alors à ce moment-là, il n'y a aucune souffrance.
La souffrance vient du fait que vous attendez quelque chose en retour.
Le problème que les gens rencontrent est l'ambition.
Alors l'autre problème que les gens ont, c'est l'ambition.
Comment vous pouvez être ambitieux et en même temps vertueux ?
Et encore une fois, c'est dans votre façon d'offrir vos talents de telle façon que, selon ce que vous pensez, que ça puisse être utile.
Donc, si vous voyez une promotion, soit dans votre emploi, soit dans un journal ou quelque chose,
Alors, si vous voyez qu'il y a une promotion qui se fait, soit au sein de la société où vous travaillez, ou alors à l'extérieur.
Et à ce moment-là, vous posez votre candidature, mais dans un acte d'offrande.
Si ce n'est pas accepté, pas de souffrance.
Et dans ce cas, s'il y a de l'offrande, et bien si votre candidature est refusée, et bien il n'y a pas de souffrance.
Et donc s'il y a de la souffrance, ça veut dire qu'il y avait de l'intention qui était un petit peu, comment on dirait donc, cheeky, insolente.
Alors, demain après-midi, il y aura du temps pour nos questions.
Et puis, il rajoute qu'en fait, toute la pratique que nous avons fait jusqu'à présent
n'a aucun sens si nous ne l'amenons pas dans notre vie courante notre problème c'est qu'on fait un effort particulier en étant ici et ensuite on sort on revient à notre vie courante et puis on oublie et rappelez-vous c'est un processus d'encourager nous-mêmes c'est tout
Et rappelez-vous que c'est un processus de s'encourager soi-même et de s'encourager gentiment.
Un des Arahats du monde moderne est Fred Astaire.
Et Ginger Rogers.
Alors, je ne sais pas si vous avez vu ce film que j'ai vu il y a fort longtemps, et il y a un moment donné où on apprend à Fred Astaire à danser.
Et il n'arrête pas de tomber.
Donc, ils nous chantent des chansons.
Et ainsi, ils chantèrent une chanson.
Alors, chaque fois que vous faites quelque chose qui n'est pas juste dans votre vie courante, c'est comme tomber par terre.
So, pick yourself up.
Et relevez-vous.
Enlevez la poussière.
Et recommencez à nouveau.
C'est tout.
Si vous avez cette image de Fred Astaire dans votre esprit, le chemin est très simple et facile.
Si vous avez l'image de Fred Astaire à votre esprit, c'est vraiment très simple, c'est vraiment très facile.
Oui, c'est la qualité d'engagement et de continuité.
Une des mots les plus utilisés et les mots que le Bouddha aimait le plus utiliser, c'était « appamado ».
Alors, un des mots que le Bouddha préférait dans l'utilisation, c'est Appamuda.
Qui veut dire diligence.
Donc, juste avant de mourir, il a dit cinq mots.
Donc, en anglais, toutes les choses composées sont impermanentes.
Alors, toutes choses conditionnées sont impermanentes.
Travaillez de manière diligente afin d'atteindre la libération.
Quels seront les derniers mots que nous prononcerons nous-mêmes ?
Pourquoi moi ?
Pourquoi pas toi ?
Très bien, j'espère que mes mots vous ont inspiré, ou en tout cas vous ont un peu inspiré, et que vous essayez délicatement de vous libérer,
et que vous arrivez à cet état d'extase plutôt que plus tard oui parce que pour moi l'extase signifie quelque chose tellement plein de passion que j'ai des difficultés avec ce mot qu'est-ce que vous utiliseriez ?
I don't know, but I know.
Béatitude.
Béatitude, yes?
Oui, béatitude.
Oui, voilà, béatitude.
Merci.
Bon, very good.
Salut.